روايه متضاربه حول تفجير روسيا ترقبون
امريكي لمحاكمه ترامب في نيويورك وجريمه
مزدوجه تهز مصر هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقولها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
البدايه من روسيا حيث اتهمت موسكو
للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه وموالينا للمعارضه
الروسي المعتقل اليكسا ناباني للوقوف وراء
تفجير المقهى
والذي ادى لمقتل مدورين عسكري وعده اصابات
السلطات الروسيه اعلنت اعتقال مرتين
الاشتباه بقيامها بادخال القنبله الى
المقهى امام مجموعه فاجنر فاستبعد قائلها
الذي يمتلك المقهى نظريه وقوف كياف وراء
التفجير ورجعا ان يكون خلفه متطرفين ليسوا
على صله بالحكومه
بترقب كبير ينتظر الامريكيون مشهدا غير
مسبوق في تاريخ الولايات المتحده حيث
سيمكن الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امام
محكمه منهاتن بعد اقل من 24 ساعه من الان
راقبونا مرتيون توقعون ترامسا يعمل كل صور
الحدث بدا من سير في ممر المحكمه نحو
قوسها وصولا الى مشهد جلوسه امام القاضي
وذلك لحفل التعاطف وجمع التبرعات
والاعلانات لحمله الانتخابيه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
والان الى مصر حيث هزت جريمه المزدوجه
شهدت مدينه السادس من اكتوبر في القاهره
هزت الشارع المصري حيث اقدم رجل على نحر
طليقته وطعنها بسكين في الشارع وامام
الماره حتى لفظت انفسها الاخيره الام لم
يتوقف عند هذا الحد حيث لم يقف اهل الحي
الذي شهد الجريمه مكتوفي الايدي عليه
بالضرب قبل ان يتم نقل المستشفى خلال
تواجده هناك لاحقه شقيق المجني عليها
وطعنه بالسكين انتقاما لمقتل شقيقته
بعد مرور الاف السنين على وفاتها توصل
فريق من العلماء الى النوع العطر الذي
كانت الملكه كليوباترا تستخدمه واستطاع
العلماء فكروا موز العطر الذي كتبت وصفته
او كتبت وصفته في النقوش المحفوره على
جدران المعابد وكشفوا ان صانع العذر
تمكنوا من التوصل اليه بعد تسخين الزيت
لمده 10 ايام قبل ان نقع في الاخشاب فيما
وصف احد الباحثين رائحه العطر بانها دافئه
وغنيه وتتميز بنكهه خفيفه من القرفه
وفي حديث جديد خرجت نحو 25 عربه قطار عن
مسارها في ولايه موريتانيا الامريكيه حيث
تكرر كثيرا هذا النوع من الحوادث في
الولايات المتحده مؤخرا وفيما لم ترد
انباء عن وقوع اصابات في مقاله كل الشرطه
الولايه وشركه مونتانا المالكه الا عربات
القطارات لم تحوي على اي مواد خطره فانه
يجلس تحقيق في سبب انحرافها عن مسارها انه
ليس هناك ما يدعو للخوف
[موسيقى]